es uno más de los 17 millones de
mexicanos contagiados
el presidente del país andrés manuel
lópez obrador dio positivo por el
coronavirus el mandatario ha sido
fuertemente criticado por la gestión que
ha hecho de la pandemia de coronavirus
en el país
desde el inicio de la emergencia
minimizó su impacto siento que no vamos
a atender problemas mayores y mientras
otros países de la región imponían
restricciones su administración se
resistía no dejen
salir todavía estamos en la primera fase
ya nosotros yo les voy a decir cuando no
salga a pesar de haber sufrido un
infarto y padecer hipertensión rara vez
se le ha visto con una mascarilla en
público a lo largo de la pandemia ha
continuado sus viajes y mítines por
diferentes puntos del país y ha seguido
saludando a sus simpatizantes con
apretones de manos y abrazos donde el
coronavirus eso sí que no se puede uno
abrazar
hay que abrazarse si no pasa nada o sea
éste
así promovió dudosos métodos para una
supuesta protección ante el contagio de
este ente
detente
ahora ambos se une a otros líderes
mundiales que han contraído la
enfermedad como el ex presidente
estadounidense donald trump el
presidente brasileño jair bolsonaro o el
primer ministro británico boris johnson
también ellos restaron importancia al
impacto del virus y se negaron al inicio
de la pandemia a imponer restricciones
el primer caso de la enfermedad se
detectó a finales de febrero en ese país
menos de un año después ya suma 150.000
muertes por corona virus méxico es la
cuarta nación a nivel mundial con mayor
número de muertes por esa enfermedad